when you talk about america standing on
the international stage with all the
controversy about the olympics the
olympic team right now and
not even to get into any one of the
specifics but you just you
you look at when i was a kid we had the
dream team you remember that 1992
that was the first year they allowed
professionals to play on the olympic
team because we
i think the u.s had gotten spanked by
the soviets the year before or two years
before or something
and they were like all right none or i
guess the olympics before because it's
obviously
union then they said all right we're
gonna allow professionals and then you
have like
jordan and scottie pippen and charles
barkley
and carl malone patrick ewing et cetera
like they're all
larry bird and they're they're all there
on one team right and they just dominate
like the most dominant team ever put
together
right but then you look at magic johnson
who's on the team and then you go
and you just look at the caliber of like
olympic athletes and it's just
kind of it's it's get what go broke man
in our standing
in the work and this this woke stuff
doesn't fly on the international stage
so here in the united states you have to
kind of make this performative
you know agreement this adherence logan
paul of course he bends the knee to
you know kendeism crt-ism and
you sort of have to it's like in china
where you have to say oh yeah i support
the ccp whether you do or not right
you have to say it because that is your
theory of the state well our the theory
of our state now
has almost become so it used to be that
uh
i can remember within living memory that
if somebody botched i think it was lady
gaga like botched the the national
anthem
at something and she was ridiculed for
it right i mean it was a huge deal
now it's considered positive
and laudatory to ridicule the national
anthem and to protest it well
let's let's let's uh on the
international stage you can see
the decline of america as a nation
simone biles simone biles i mean it
so i don't know simon biles i don't know
her story i'm sure she has one i'm a
catholic i
i pray for her the same way i would pray
for everybody else i think i think she
actually is catholic i might be wrong
about that but i think she is
um and she dropped out
well i think i think she got pulled out
the issue for me did you pull her did
she get dropped
i think took herself out yeah i thought
she took her and now she's out
completely i guess
and so the issue for me though is
why is it as a society now i'm told
right
right and i i pray for her i i pray for
simone biles but at the same time
i'm not going to go to my son and say
that
you should make your role model she's a
catholic she is catholic right
i thought i was right i think she wore a
metal miraculous medal at one point
that's how i knew and um my brother
posted something
and i'm not going to go to my son and
say hey let's celebrate someone for not
accomplishing
that's where we've been going for a long
time with the
honor roll mentioned the participation
trophies that kind of thing
so uh simone biles man uh she's best of
the best i mean she's
she's incredible she landed in i guess
in qualifier
they got mad because she did that double
urachenko whatever it was called i'm not
a gymnastics person
well the idea was that it was she had
surpassed the previous
skill level and they didn't even have a
skill level for
the defeat that she attempted so she
wouldn't gain she would get her name in
the book
for like a maneuver or whatever and so
she's doing really really well
but uh she flubbed a few moves then
because of her mental health
pulled out that is that is that is an
uh uh indication of the failure of our
culture
that you would have an olympic athlete
having those mental issues
like not getting i mean proper training
isn't just your your
your body it's your mind and your body
and so a breakdown of an athlete is a
failure
across the board it's it's right i mean
i take this as an indictment of
the entire social strata yeah that put
her into that position that puts us all
into this position
and then we celebrate it right you look
at the response
of the actual story here isn't simone
biles
the actual story is that if you were a
journalist in sports today
and you said something that went against
the grain
and said that you you disagreed with
that decision or that you don't
celebrate what happened
you would lose your job you know you
would lose your job in america
today i'm sick of the hive mind man you
know you went against the hive
you're done charlie kirk he was
recording his podcast and he said that
simone biles gave a gift or something to
the russian something like that
and then i just i think yeah the
russians got the gold medal right and
then i see a bunch of these posts
everyone's like charlie's so dumb like
phil defranco comes out like charlie's a
dick and i'm like
shut up dude phil listen you don't know
anything about charlie
okay he's a guy with an opinion all this
is is people with with no opinions
who don't actually care and have any
thoughts of their own wading into stupid
drama
let me tell you something if somebody
wants to opine on simone biles who is
like the cream of the crop the best of
the best in the olympics
and she bails out for mental health
issues and they have a negative view of
that i say interesting
am i going to make a video where i'm
like oh that charlie kirk who cares
charlie crook's a commentator a pining
on opinions is the stupidest thing ever
but out of the woodwork comes every
stupid person
who's like i've got nothing better to
say but then to just rag on a guy who
had an opinion about a thing which is
totally irrelevant to the olympics and
the conversation right but that
that hive mind provoked response is
actually quite useful for us
because it is revealing to us
in its response to defend itself we are
seeing
the contours of the hive mind in and of
itself i just you know i despise npcs
it's just you know i've just the the
conformists who don't read who don't
learn who don't think who just say tell
me what to do
i've never been i've never been favored
that i grew up when i was younger
i i i wouldn't say that i was like you
know the punks get mad when i'm like oh
i listen to pong you said no you didn't
name a band and i'm like shut up
name a band the virus or whatever
hanging out with a bunch of people who
played a bunch of crazy punk music and
the main thing was
we were anti-establishment we were
skateboarders we were running from cops
and security guards and we said the
system is broke and we don't care
your rules are stupid screw your your
conformity
and now what we have are these people on
the left who still think they're punk
rock
right they're as anti-punk rock as you
can get charlie kirk is trending on
twitter and i look at it i'm like
why why do these people care about
charlie kirk
they don't what they care about is
virtue signaling
letting everybody know i'm cool i'm part
of the tribe too so i'm going to talk
about this guy that's not relevant to
the olympics
it's a waste of my time if if i want to
bring up something about simone biles
i don't even think i'm relevant to the
conversation if people want to listen to
what i have to say about it they can but
she's the center
she's the center focus of this i think
it's really bad that we're celebrating
there was a there was a there was like a
news article where it's like why is it
in
in today's society we want to celebrate
mental health as if that is something in
itself which should be celebrated
rather than achievement for
achievement's sake because we are
losing our mental health it used to be
that
we had our mental health we were
resilient we were mature
we could deal with crises and hardship
and we could do it with a with a
straight face
right the opposite of mental disorder is
mental resilience do you
do you were you were in the navy you
were a submarine right uh
i would spend some time on a sub yeah
have you ever have you ever have you
ever been on a
on a naval vessel during a crisis um
training and well yeah i guess you could
say yeah you ever you know i've been in
some heightened situations
you ever see a general just start like
breaking down saying i'm i'm gonna leave
the battle because of my mental health
this is not something i can be dealing
with right now and they're like you know
honorable general good for you well you
don't see that on twitter every day now
with these generals oh yeah i know
mark milly man that guy lost his mark
milly this guy pat donahoe
who said you're being a shill for putin
if you say i've asked provide
will he by the way private you know set
his account to private today
oh right but these guys can't handle a
twitter war
how could they actually ever handle a
real war could you imagine
taking one of these you know i think i
said this last time i was on here but
the and i i do this to to make a point
the u.s navy would not be
prepared to defend taiwan in a scenario
if china wanted to take it tomorrow oh
yeah yeah right they would lose they
would lose and imagine what that would
do
to the american psyche overnight to
lose in a state on state conflict like
that a near pure competitor
where you'd have half the country well
you'd have to have the country cheering
for it but think of the american right
and think of the conservative americans
and even think of like a lot of just
sort of the
you know kind of normie americans out
there you're sort of like
hey i'm just kind of going through life
and doing my thing america is the best
etc right
when you're told you are not the best
and you understand that your system is
no i i don't i think the average person
won't care
i think the average democrat will be
like hey it's none of our business good
for china and they would cheer it on
and they would say you know it's
actually a good thing that china has
reclaimed taiwan because
you know it's we shouldn't be meddling
in their affairs all of a sudden
becoming anti-war in that in that regard
you would see regular people i'll be
clear i don't want to go to war with
china no no i don't know
i really don't but you would see regular
people say oh
i've had too many conversations with
with with regular people when i lived in
new york where you know people who don't
pay attention to politics
regular people politically uninitiated
and i'll be like
so uh that obama yeah one of the first
things he did when he got into office
was he bombed a pakistani village
killing like 23 women and children and
they go
oh i'm like do you care no well here's
the difference right here's what i think
is different is that it's not about
to the average american it wouldn't be
about taiwan it would be about
america clearly and definitively
losing a war yeah but which is something
that
if china goes you know you look at a lot
of wars like 1812 did the us really won
the
you know not so much well everybody
claims you know they claim that the
claim in the u.s has never lost a war
but
how tenable is that at this point right
regular people
here's what i think would happen china
will move to take taiwan they'll they'll
go from the air they'll take out the
the you know any opposition on the
ground they'll beach the the island
and they'll take it over and it'll be
big breaking news
and then the left will claim to have
some expertise all these stupid twitter
people who don't actually read and see
facebook memes will be like well here's
what i think about taiwan i don't care
what you think about taiwan
and then regular people are going to be
like huh and then something will happen
their computers will double in cost or
triple in cost or just become
unavailable because what does taiwan
have
chips all your microchips your
semiconductors your transistors
that entire industry right and by the
way
i wish this wasn't the situation i wish
that a lot of that was onshored to the
united states
but again by policy since the 1990s
we've been offshoring all this stuff san
diego by the way san diego was the
birthplace of this industry
and all of it was shipped overseas to
taiwan and korea yep right
all of this was this country has been
extracted dylan radigan said it a long
time ago maybe not in the same context
but a similar context
the country has been extracted you know
i think happened i think 2008 was a
wake-up call for a lot of people a lot
of democrats
you know look you look at bernie sanders
in 2008 and he's like we need a border
barrier
open borders are a bad thing you see
hillary clinton and pelosi and biden
they're all like we must build a border
barrier
illegal immigration is bad and then the
economic collapse happened and they said
well we just hit an iceberg i'm gonna
try and steal as much silverware as
possible before i get on a life raft
right and so the idea of the obama
administration and they're quite open
about this if you actually look
at what the uh the national security
advisors and the deputy national degree
advisers ben rhodes et cetera have
actually said
in their own writings they said since
the united states
is in what we're what we're putting it
into is a managed decline
right we know that we are going to need
help from
our peers in other regions of the world
to be able to enforce things so
why should we be the ones who are
enforcing international norms and
international laws maybe china can help
us out
maybe maybe we can pass off some of this
responsibility to china
when it comes to the asia there's a life
draft a life raft for everybody in my
opinion
and uh i'm not going to tell you what to
do with your money take financial advice
from somebody else but i think it's
bitcoin
right so again we've been put in this
path by policy
right that's clear we don't have to be
on it right we we can get off of it
we can we can right the ship you know
this this has all
gone on within the last 30 years that's
not that much time
right we can actually make these
decisions however people need to
understand
that there are massive economic
interests in between us
righting the ship or staying on this
path towards managed decline
and serfdom and a the rise of a new
peasant slave
class of the the underlings right the
under society
right so you have an over society that's
pushing for all these things to happen
they are stateless they are
multinational uh they're tied in
with the ccp they're tied in with
everything else and they want you to be
the the consumer right your job is to
consume uh
you are like if you watch wall-e right
you know you're you're the guy who's
sitting there and you're in your chair
and you don't even have a my pillow
and you're you're hooked up to the
machine
you're tweeting and there's there's
actually this great that's why they
don't talk about wally that much anymore
because i think it was too real
and a lot of christian uh some um
symbolism in there eve and it's like an
arc right of humanity
um where there's this joke as while he's
going around everyone's in a blue suit
he turns them into red when they they
become activated and then there's this
running gag
like wait we have a pool right and they
kind of realize that their screens go
off and they realize instead of just
trending
and they're just commenting it's
facebook right so they're all just
commenting on like
the minutia of day-to-day life and they
have no bones
they have no yeah they have no bones and
they have like slushies that are
you know ordered to their cart whenever
they need it and then suddenly they
you know they start realizing like hey
we're we're in outer space like this is
pretty cool and
we have a pool we're on a nice ship we
can you know talk to each other you know
why i don't think wally would happen
in one one aspect everyone being we
never be able to make a ship that works
no no no um there's a physiological uh
addiction to athletics you know to to to
to sports and to exercise
so while certainly a lot of people get
addicted to people maybe for sure but
but
the idea that every single person would
be overweight just floating around in
chairs there's a lot of people who would
get that hit that dopamine that runner's
high maybe those people refuse to get on
the ship
yeah i guess no we'll just die here on
earth or something we're just going to
die here with the trash piles man and
trash piles
first we get to graphene okay is that
how you think again sounds
i don't know i'm just kind of doing a
character at that point he's like dude
he's not that bad yeah he's not he's
probably watching he's like jack
i don't sound like that uh you know what
man you know here's my here's my
prediction i've been saying this for a
while
uh vaccines will be mandatory in my
opinion it's going to be like this uh
you'll do that
i think everyone knows that's coming
i need your vaccination card and a a
bill with your address on it
and they'll go oh yeah i got it all
right here i'll go okay and then i'll
type it i'm like here's your id
it'll be a part of the process like
normal like we saw with that photo of
the airport is that is that a real photo
you see that where it's like
that was my buddy john dutois who worked
on um we were
a ton of film projects together and he
said it wasn't his photo but someone had
sent it to him he's canadian
um so i haven't i haven't fact check it
but he said that
it was a separate airport line coming
into canada so
canadian customs line one for vax needed
one for unboxing
yeah uh de blasio said the voluntary
phase is over i mean this reminds me of
uh
gattaca remember the valids and the
invalids
oh i haven't seen it within a long time
oh that's everything but i bring this up
because the the to paint a picture of
this future where americans don't make
stuff
americans are like wally but you know
not like floating around hover chairs
wouldn't have harvard chairs
but they're mostly gonna do nothing
they're becoming more and more obese
they don't work they get free money from
the government it is a managed decline
giving people this money you know tesla
said this in the 1920s what managed
decline
no he said that we that um we will
reach a point with materialism where the
average
person lives as if they're in a bee
colony he predicted bug men
i think the unemployment benefits are
them lowering down people into economic
collapse
they're they're trying to hold you back
from from you know going nuts as the
economy
implodes while they shuffle off overseas
their assets and resources
oh yeah and they buy a bitcoin and
things like that and then you're sitting
here going like well i'm getting my
money and then
one day rug gets pulled out from under
you and you are a serf
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you